hi I'm Zack woods and these are my
favorite YouTube videos
Bill Clinton putting down hecklers at
rallies is the finest YouTube has to
offer there's one in particular
Clinton's angry response to heckler it
is at the light that Crimson said
basically like a pro wrestler like he
takes the mic off the stand and he gets
all red in the face and he just turns
into like Jerry the King Lawler it is a
true diamond there's another category of
YouTube videos that I highly recommend
for some reason the Canadian government
created all of these PSAs the sous chef
here they're the least specific PSAs
I've ever seen the PSAs are just about
don't make mistakes because I'm about to
be a terrible accident it's not like
don't do drugs it's not like don't drive
drunk it's just like just be really
careful I should have cleaned up the
grease over there and they should never
put the deep fryer so please
they are the most horrifyingly graphic
violent videos and then it says there
really are no accidents
it's insane I'm a big fan of wake up
pranks because I'm a [ __ ] wake up
pranks are when somebody that somebody
else trusts it wakes them up in a
terrible way when they're asleep and
normally when people are woken up in
these wake up pranks they are angry at
their friends but this guy just looks up
at the sky and screams as if like a
complaint to God it's me and it's
juvenile and it makes me laugh harder
than anything else I've ever seen okay
what's another good one battle at Kruger
Park this is not a funny one but it's
weirdly emotional there's a bunch of
water buffalo and a bunch of lions come
in and they try to kill the water
buffalo and one of the Lions gets a hold
of the baby he's going for me
damn an alligator comes out of the river
and grabs the other side of the water
buffalo so it's this horrific tug-of-war
between a lion and an alligator you're
thinking like why would you ever watch
this this sounds heartbreaking and it is
but then all of the adult water
buffaloes read Greek and they come back
hard
oh my head but I mean you seem like a
lion do like a 360 in the air the Cavs
still alive and they rescue the baby and
the baby's okay it's the most gangster
[ __ ] I'm just seen in my life like these
water buffalos going back to fight a
pack of lions and they will either chase
demoys for my last video
I'd recommend falling asleep at the
wheel while rapping this is technically
I think I'm blind and I got put on
YouTube so you know throw me in jail
there's these two guys I was kind of
making a beat well whatever you don't
you just watch the video it's amazing
hey Ronnie HD okay okay we're going to
ask for more from life than they thank
you for allowing me to evangelize about
my favorite YouTube video
they're incredible have you guys seen
these oh my god they are so amazing